[Musik]
>> SALLY: Wir machen jetzt Elas 50 Minuten.
>> ELA: Ja!
[Musik]
Oi, oi, oi!
So.
Hilfst du mir heute?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte.
Die Schürze ist hier, wenn du eine willst.
Willst du eine?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay. Komm mal da hoch.
>> ELA: Ich habe aber auch eine eigene Schürze.
>> SALLY: Wer macht den Anfang?
Ich oder du?
>> ELA: Ich!
>> SALLY: Du oder ich?
Du?
Okay.
Dann begrüß mal.
Eins,
>> SALLY & ELA: zwei,
drei.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
>> SALLY: Was machen wir heute?
>> ELA: Einen Kuchen!
>> SALLY: Oh! Das hast du aber gut geraten.
Und zwar machen wir heute einen Cheesecake,
einen Käsekuchen.
Aber keinen normalen Cheesecake!
Denn wir machen heute einen San Sebastián Cheesecake.
Der San Sebastián Cheesecake kommt nicht,
wie viele denken, aus Istanbul,
sondern aus San Sebastián.
Das ist eine Stadt am Golf von Biskaya
im bergigen Baskenland in Spanien.
Die Stadt ist bekannt für ihre Strände
Playa de la Concha und Playa de Ondarreta
und auch für die weltberühmten Restaurants
und die innovative Küche.
Das La Viña ist ein hübsches Restaurant
mit Café in der Altstadt.
Und da gibt es eine richtig besondere Spezialität:
den San Sebastián Cheesecake.
Und dieser zeichnet sich dadurch aus,
dass er außen fast verbrannt aussieht
und im Inneren aber noch sehr cremig und fast roh ist.
Typische Käsekuchen haben nämlich klassischerweise
eine goldgelbe Farbe und sind im Inneren durchgebacken.
Womöglich hat vor vielen Jahren ein Bäckerlehrling
den Käsekuchen aus lediglich fünf Zutaten zubereitet
und ihn fälschlicherweise dann
in den falschen Backofen gestellt.
Der Kuchen verbrannte dann von außen
und war innen nicht durch.
Statt aber seinen Fehler einzugestehen
und den Kuchen erneut richtig zu backen,
ließ der Lehrling den verbrannten Käsekuchen abkühlen
und servierte ihn als neue Spezialität des Hauses.
Der Kuchen kam bei den Gästen sehr gut an
und jeder sprach darüber.
Und seit diesem Tag gibt es
den Burnt San Sebastián Cheesecake zu kaufen
und er zieht jeden Tag Einheimische
und auch ganz viele Touristen in die Stadt.
Mittlerweile wird der Kuchen
auch in vielen anderen Städten zubereitet,
wie zum Beispiel in Istanbul,
wo wir ihn auch vor einigen Jahren schon probieren durften.
Eine Reise nach San Sebastián
lohnt sich also auf jeden Fall!
Für den Cheesecake braucht ihr nur
ein Kilo Frischkäse in Doppelrahmstufe,
350 Gramm Zucker,
40 Gramm Mehl,
fünf Eier,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und 500 Gramm Sahne.
Während Ela die Schüssel holt,
werde ich schon mal die Backform vorbereiten.
Das wird jetzt gleich eine richtig flüssige Masse.
Daher backe ich jetzt hier in einem Tortenring.
Aber ich muss den Tortenring in Backpapier einschlagen.
Und jetzt habe ich einen Tipp für euch.
Und zwar nehmt ihr jetzt
einen Bogen Backpapier.
Das war jetzt Samiras Tipp,
also von meiner kleinen Großen,
meiner Tochter Samira.
Legt es hier drauf.
Den Backring habe ich jetzt
auf 25 cm Durchmesser eingestellt.
Oh, du hast ja echt eine Schüssel geholt!
Cool!
Willst du nicht die Glasschüssel?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder sollen wir deine nehmen?
>> ELA: Nein, meine.
>> SALLY: Deine?
Okay. Aber dann sehen halt die Zuschauer nicht so viel, nicht?
Doch vielleicht eine Glasschüssel?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Weil du bekommst ja jetzt auch einen rosanen
Rührlöffel und dann sieht man den rosanen Rührlöffel auch.
Okay?
Also guck mal. Und dann stelle ich es dir hier drauf.
Dann rutscht die Schüssel auch nicht. Okay?
Wenn du gleich rührst.
Okay. Kommen wir zurück zu meinem Backformtrick.
Das ist ein Trick von Samira.
Und zwar nehmt ihr jetzt einfach einen anderen Tortenring,
der etwas größer eingestellt ist.
Warte. Ich zeige euch das hier.
Stellt den hier drauf
und den hier mit dem Backpapier rein.
Und dann einfach zuziehen.
Und dann habt ihr praktisch
die innere Backform mit Backpapier eingekleidet,
ohne dass ihr das außenrum wickeln müsst.
Und hier innen den Rand lege ich jetzt noch
mit einem Backpapierstreifen aus.
Das braucht der Cheesecake auch.
Einfach hier an den Rand legen.
Und hier oben kann man es einschneiden und umknicken.
Dann bleibt es nämlich auch schön dran, gell?
So?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Backform ist vorbereitet.
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Yay!
Guck mal. Du kriegst jetzt einen Schneebesen.
Dafür braucht man jetzt nämlich gar keine Küchenmaschine.
Ihr nehmt einfach eine Rührschüssel, einen Schneebesen
oder einen Kochlöffel
und das war es.
Denn der Käsekuchen, der soll schön cremig sein,
nicht luftig.
Daher keine Luft einschlagen.
Und dann spart man sich auch das ganze Geschirr, gell?
Und hier ist jetzt nur noch wichtig,
dass alle Zutaten Raumtemperatur haben.
Also wirklich den Frischkäse und die Eier
früh genug rauslegen.
Okay.
Jetzt kannst du schon mal rühren.
Das geht noch schwierig.
Aber gleich, wenn der Zucker dazu kommt,
geht es einfacher.
Also gebe ich jetzt noch den Zucker dazu.
>> ELA: Den ganzen.
>> SALLY: Den ganzen.
So.
>> ELA: Huch!
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich hätte auch
mein Leopardenkleid anziehen sollen, hä?
Dann wären wir im Partnerlook.
Rühren! Rühren!
Soll ich noch ein bisschen helfen?
>> ELA: Nein. Das...
>> SALLY: Nein. Das kriegst du hin.
Und jetzt geben wir ein Ei nach dem anderen dazu.
Immer nur ein Ei.
Zack.
Jetzt das Ei schön einrühren.
Guck. Schön langsam.
Hier außen.
Keine Luft einschlagen,
sondern nur cremig rühren.
>> ELA: Rühren!
>> SALLY: Und?
>> ELA: Lecker.
>> SALLY: Jetzt schon lecker, hä?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ein Ei haben wir noch.
Das kommt auch noch rein.
Aber guck mal.
Komm, ich helfe dir kurz.
>> ELA: Jetzt.
Jetzt kommt das andere Ei!
>> SALLY: Ja!
Wupsi!
Juhu!
>> ELA: Ich will!
>> SALLY: Den Ofen habe ich jetzt auch schon vorgeheizt.
Und zwar wähle ich da die Heizstufe Heißluft
und wirklich die heißeste Einstellung, die bei euch geht.
Bei mir an dem Ofen sind es 275°C.
250°C reichen aber auch vollkommen aus.
Super machst du das! Ganz, ganz toll!
Jetzt kommt Vanilleextrakt dazu.
>> ELA: Ich will!
>> SALLY: Ganz wenig.
Denn du weißt, das ist hochkonzentriert.
Super!
Und dann geben wir jetzt noch Mehl und Salz dazu.
Das darfst du machen.
Alles schön klümpchenfrei.
Komm, schütte es einfach rein, Schatz.
>> ELA: Aber ich mache es lieber immer so.
>> SALLY: Okay. Dann mach es halt lieber immer so.
>> ELA: Eins nach dem anderen.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
Eins nach dem anderen.
Sehr gut!
[Musik]
Dann wird er noch besser.
Also eigentlich ist das so eine
Zubereitungszeit von fünf Minuten,
drei.
Wir machen jetzt Elas 50 Minuten.
Oh!
Kannst du mal bei Papas fünf Minuten mitmachen?
Murats 5 Minuten!
Was macht der Papa immer?
>> ELA: Handy.
>> SALLY: Handy?
Handy!
Upsala!
Hoppala, Murat!
Gut. Willst du die Sahne reinschütten?
Oder willst du rühren?
>> ELA: Ich will die Sahne reinschütten.
>> SALLY: Okay. Ganz langsam reinschütten, ja?
>> ELA: Eins nach dem anderen.
>> SALLY: Ja, mach ruhig.
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja. Ja! Ja!
Ojemine!
So. Jetzt hier die Sahne noch einrühren.
>> ELA: Ich will!
>> SALLY: Und ich sehe jetzt schon,
die Masse ist relativ flüssig.
>> ELA: Ich will!
Nee!
>> SALLY: Du darfst. Aber vorsichtig, okay?
Nicht so große Kreise.
Sonst verschütten wir aus Versehen.
Upsala.
>> ELA: Wow!
Guck mal, Mama!
>> SALLY: Voll gut machst du das!
[Musik]
Also hier jetzt einfach schauen,
dass alle Zutaten gut verbunden sind.
Ihr seht, das ist echt kein Hexenwerk.
Einfach nur cremig verrührt.
>> ELA: Mit einer Kanne großer Sahne!
>> SALLY: Mh?
>> ELA: In der Kanne...
>> SALLY: Und jetzt wird das hier reingefüllt.
>> SALLY: Okay. Einmal Finger rein reicht aber.
[Musik]
Ich kenne kein Kind, das genüsslicher Teig nascht,
als Ela.
So.
Dann ein bisschen verstreichen.
Und wie gesagt, kommt jetzt der Cheesecake
in den vorgeheizten Backofen
bei höchster Einstellung.
Ich mache jetzt Heißluft 250°C.
275°C.
Ihr könnt auch 250°C machen.
Er muss von außen schön braun werden,
innen aber noch wabbelig sein.
Ich zeige euch gleich
den Kuchen nach dem Backen.
Und dann verkosten wir.
[Musik]
So.
Nach 25 Minuten sieht der Kuchen bei mir jetzt so aus.
Perfekt, würde ich sagen.
Außen oder oben schön dunkel geworden.
Aber in der Mitte noch richtig wacklig.
Den nehme ich jetzt aus dem Ofen heraus
und lasse ihn komplett abkühlen.
Jetzt durfte der Käsekuchen schön auskühlen.
Den äußeren Tortenring habe ich schon
vor der Abkühlzeit weg,
damit er schneller abkühlt.
Wunderbar.
Ein Tortenretter.
Jetzt ziehe ich das Backpapier weg.
Am besten einfach umschlagen
und dann darunter wegrollen.
Also so finde ich ihn gar nicht mal schlecht.
Und...
Also außen hätte er noch ein bisschen dunkler werden dürfen.
Ich glaube, das kam jetzt aber auch daher,
dass die Back-,
also die Wand der Backform jetzt ziemlich dick war.
Aber so
finde ich ihn gar nicht schlecht.
Ja.
Ich glaube, wir verkosten den jetzt,
den San Sebastián Cheesecake.
[Musik]
So. Das ist er, der Cheesecake.
Die Fotos, die ich gesehen habe von San Sebastián,
also
aus dem La Viña,
die sind sogar noch dunkler.
Also da ist wirklich der Rand überall dunkel.
Und hier,
man sieht es schon...
Ela?
Ela will die Klappe.
Man sieht es hier auch schon,
die Haut da oben, die löst sich.
Und dort ist es wirklich so,
die oberste Schicht, die oberste Schicht, die löst sich voll ab.
>> MURAT: Also das ist so ein Kuchen,
wo man wirklich mal sagen kann:
>> SALLY: Komm rüber.
>> MURAT: "Okay. Der ist verbrannt."
>> SALLY: Aber der gehört halt so.
>> MURAT: Der gehört halt so.
So.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss sagen, als ich den
das erste Mal gebacken habe, habe ich ihn so gebacken.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich ein schöner Käsekuchen, nicht?
>> MURAT: Ich würde auch eher den...
>> SALLY: Also ich würde optisch eher den nehmen.
>> MURAT: Ja, würde ich auch nehmen.
>> SALLY: Aber so ist das Original.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und der ist auch sehr lecker.
>> MURAT: Dann probieren wir jetzt mal?
>> SALLY: Wir probieren jetzt.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Innen drinnen muss der ja
>> SALLY: Cremig sein.
>> MURAT: cremig sein.
>> SALLY: Ich habe halt den Ofen wirklich ausgereizt.
275°C.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Man merkt jetzt auch eins.
Ich meine, der schwabbelt, gell?
>> SALLY: Der schwabbelt.
Der ist richtig wabbelig.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ela, weißt du, was wabbelig heißt?
>> ELA: Was?
>> SALLY: Wabbelig.
>> MURAT: Wabbelig.
>> SALLY: Was ist wabbelig?
>> ELA: Weiß ich gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Was ist noch wabbelig?
Wabbel, wabbel, wabbel.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Weiter.
Wir probieren jetzt einfach.
>> SALLY: Okay. Wir probieren.
>> MURAT: Da klopft es die ganze Zeit bei uns.
Hört ihr das?
>> MURAT: Hör mal. Als wären wir im Busch.
>> SALLY: Yay!
>> ELA: Das ist ein Flieder!
>> SALLY: Da innen sieht man, der ist einfach megacremig.
Und jetzt
wird der einfach so hingelegt.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Dort war er sogar noch ein bisschen dicker.
Oh, ich habe Gabeln geholt.
Ich muss Löffel holen.
Wartet. Das war falsch.
Falsch, Samira. Warte.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt einfach von oben nach unten löffeln.
>> MURAT: Das ist einfach nur die Creme, gell?
>> SALLY: Guckt mal, wie geschmeidig!
>> MURAT: So.
>> SAMIRA: Der ist noch warm.
>> MURAT: Aber du musst ehrlich sein. Okay?
>> SALLY: Noch lauwarm, nicht?
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Boah!
Richtig cool!
>> SALLY: Megacremig.
>> MURAT: Boah!
Ela, wie findest du den?
>> SALLY: Also meine Mama würde jetzt einfach sagen:
"Bu pasta pişmemiş. Der ist nicht durch."
>> MURAT: Nee. Ich finde den richtig lecker.
>> SALLY: Aber
>> MURAT: Aber der ist echt so wie so ein Joghurt, finde ich.
>> SALLY: mega!
>> MURAT: Gell?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ihr wisst, wenn Murat Joghurt sagt,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: ist das ein Lob für mich.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Boah, der schmeckt auch richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mega!
>> MURAT: Ich mag den auch verbrannt.
>> SALLY: Aber weißt du, wie ich den gerne
ausprobieren würde?
>> MURAT: Wie?
>> SALLY: Wirklich in so einem richtigen Steinofen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weißt du? Bei offenem Feuer.
Bei offenem Feuer in so einem Brotofen.
Weil ich glaube dann,
so bekommen die das dort hin.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Richtig heiß, ein ganz heißer Ofen.
Und dann ist er noch wabbeliger innen.
Mega!
Also das Rezept solltet ihr unbedingt mal ausprobieren!
Ein Cheesecake mit nur sechs Zutaten,
ganz einfach verrührt, ohne Küchenmaschine.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich habe ja nur meine lebendige Waschmaschine
dabei gehabt,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: die immer schön alle Schüsseln
wieder leer leckt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die Ela.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Das Rezept gibt es in meiner kostenlosen App
und natürlich auf sallys-blog.de.
Macht den Kuchen nach! Probiert ihn aus!
>> MURAT: Der ist saugut!
>> SALLY: Gebt ihm eine Chance!
>> MURAT: Ela.
>> SALLY: Und postet eure Kommentare
gerne unter das Video.
>> ELA: Mhm. Ich bin voll.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ich meine, das ist auch cool,
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: der schmeckt jetzt so richtig so karamellig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das ist das Besondere.
Außen richtig karamellig, so malzig
aromatisch.
Hammerlecker!
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ein Foto und dann essen wir den Rest.
Den vernichten wir.
>> MURAT: Den will man gar nicht zeigen.
Er schmeckt echt lecker.
Ohne Witz.
Macht das nach!
>> SALLY: Richtig gut!
Tschüss!
[Musik]